the Met Gala might be known for its high
fashion but it's the cute couple moments
that have us saluting we're counting
down the 7 sweetest celebrity twosomes
to strut up the galas famous steps
starting with Jennifer Lopez and Alex
Rodriguez the pair made their red carpet
debut at the 2017 Met Gala where a rod
proved he's the ultimate Instagram
boyfriend snapping his lady as she
posted up for the cameras but if you
thought that was cute just look how
adorable now that is what we call goals
next up Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra
the two famously posed together on the
Met stairs in 2017 while modeling their
custom Ralph Lauren looks while the now
husband and wife were not an official
couple at the time the flirty photos
caused fans to speculate about a
potential romance between the two
well sparks flew and the rest is history
the lovebirds tied the knot in December
2018 and were named co-hosts for the
2019 Met Gala to be honest like I'm very
excited I love to make out it's always a
fun night but you know Priyanka will set
the tone and I'm just gonna be there to
support so I'll keep it simple at her
shine then there was Selena Gomez and
The Weeknd who just couldn't keep their
hands to themselves can't keep my hands
to myself the two made their red carpet
and official couple debut at the 2017
fashion events and didn't shy away from
some serious public displays of
affection yep there they are smooching
on the Met steps and whispering sweet
nothings into each other's ears while
Selena's girly coach gown stands the
test of time their love did not the two
split just five months later and we
stand hard for Lilly Reinhart and Cole
Sprouse who made their red carpet debut
as a couple at the 2018 Met Gala Lily
looked like a literal angel in a
shimmery silver H&M gown while Cole was
all kinds of dapper in a black tux and
bowtie the two had appeared on their
fair share of red carpets together
to promote their hit show Riverdale but
this was the first time they attended an
event together after announcing their
official relationship status but nothing
was as epic as did the in Cassie's
couple moment at the 2017 Met Gala the
music mogul was happy to let his date
take center stage while he chilled in
the background but did he didn't just
stand on the sidelines he straight-up
took a seat on the Metropolitan Museum
of Art steps hilariously photobombing
Cassie's fashion moment Diddy later
explains the lacs moment on Twitter
writing I was getting tired so I laid
down on the stairs
and while the rapper proved walking the
red carpet is hard work
Tom Brady and Gisele Bundchen make it
look easy the a-list duo attends the
event every year schooling us all on how
to work it for the cameras whether it's
a stylish smooch a booty pat or a deep
longing gaze into each other's eyes
these two sure know how to heat things
up for the cameras and last but not
least there's mary-kate and Ashley Olsen
the Met Gala wouldn't be the Met Gala
without an appearance from the Olsens
the Twins have famously turned heads
since their first met moment in 2005 and
continued to transform and elevate their
style each and every year
you
[Music]